[Aplausos]
[Música]
una relación de amor o una relación de
odio queridos amigos en este vídeo nos
vamos a ocupar de una relación muy pero
que muy especial tan especial que está
cerca muy cerca de cumplir su 70
aniversario si el amor llego a visual
político
claudio hay tú no os penséis ni por un
segundo que hablamos de dos enamorados
cualquiera para nada nuestros
protagonistas se aman y se odian se
necesitan y se desprecian al mismo
tiempo me estoy refiriendo al vínculo
que une la argentina con el fondo
monetario internacional
[Música]
pero todo este tiempo tampoco hubo
acuerdo con el fondo monetario
internacional
[Música]
le pagamos le dijimos chau recuperamos
nuestra soberanía recuperamos nuestra
dignidad y el fondo monetario
internacional no viene más a conducir
los destinos de la economía de la patria
como lo hizo durante tanto tiempo el rol
del presidente de la fifa ha sido
bastante más satisfactorio que el rol
del director del fondo o de los
directores del fondo monetario
internacional
amigos los argentinos una y otra y otra
vez se prometen que no van a volver a
echarse en manos del fmi pero luego
apenas unos años más tarde la relación
vuelva a florecer frente a esta nueva
situación y de manera preventiva
he decidido iniciar conversaciones con
el fondo monetario internacional
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea desde
mediados de la década de los cincuenta
media argentina ha tenido que negociar
un rescate del fmi cada 4 años y medio
ahora bien por qué demonios la argentina
vuelve una y otra vez a depender del fm
y de quién es la culpa podrá en algún
momento de esta relación llegar a su
final vamos a verlo pero antes antes
tenemos que descubrir dónde comenzó este
romance
[Música]
el origen de un amor tóxico en el año
1946 surgió el fondo monetario
internacional como un desprendimiento de
los acuerdos de bretton woods del año 44
en aquel momento la segunda guerra
mundial acababa de terminar europa
estaba hecha añicos y los aliados
occidentales se preparaban para hacer
frente a las consecuencias económicas y
a la reconstrucción en aquel momento la
idea que existía era que había que
evitar lo sucedido tras la primera
guerra mundial es decir había que
acelerar la recuperación y evitar que se
produjeran crisis que pudieran inclinar
a algunos países hacia movimientos
radicales o incluso hacia la órbita
soviética que claro en aquel momento era
el gran enemigo con esta idea además del
plan marshall a partir de protón wood se
crearon tres instituciones que hoy todos
conocemos tres instituciones con las que
conseguir ese objetivo en primer lugar
el fondo monetariointernacional actuaría
como prestamista de última instancia
para países con fuertes desequilibrios
fiscales o crisis cambiarias
es decir el fm y aportarían los recursos
necesarios para que estos países
pudieran desarrollar reformas con las
que corregir sus desequilibrios en
segundo lugar se creó lo que hoy
conocemos como banco mundial que se
encargaría de ofrecer préstamos con
bajos
de interés y periodos de amortización de
repago de devolución de los préstamos
muy largos para ayudar así a los países
a financiar su reconstrucción y llevar a
cabo grandes proyectos de inversión y
finalmente el gat el acuerdo general
sobre aranceles aduaneros y comercio la
antesala de lo que hoy es la
organización mundial del comercio que
nació precisamente con el objetivo de
promover el libre comercio y favorecer
así el crecimiento económico
pues bien el caso es que en aquel
momento aunque sea algo que pueda
resultarnos realmente extraño lo cierto
es que el argentino era uno de los
países con mejores condiciones
económicas del planeta motivo por el que
fue invitada a integrar el fm y desde el
origen de esta institución
[Música]
pero amigos juan domingo perón que acaba
de ser elegido presidente de la
argentina no estaba por la labor digamos
que tenía en mente un modelo muy
diferente para argentinas que no tenían
nada que ver con esta especie de
integración económica a gran escala por
cierto en la descripción os dejo un link
a un par de vídeos nos contamos quién
fue juan domingo perón y qué cambios
hizo en argentina
sin embargo pronto las cosas cambiaron
cuando en el año 1955 perón fue
derrocado por un golpe de estado militar
la situación económica del país ya era
muy distinta sin reservas con altas
tasas de inflación y elevados déficit
públicos el presidente de facto pedro
eugenio aramburu decidió incorporarse al
fm y solicitar una ayuda de casi 1000
millones de dólares en valor actual en
valor de hoy
el romance había comenzado y si en ese
momento la argentina ya se parecía más a
la argentina que hoy por desgracia pues
todos conocemos pero un momento puede
que algunos estáis preguntando pero
enrique que pasa que acaso el fm irá
primero por dar le pides un préstamo en
condiciones más favorables y listo es
una ong o algo así pues no no
exactamente
veréis el fm y otorga financiación en
unas condiciones muy favorables pero
también impone condiciones que entiende
son necesarias para corregir los
problemas y recuperar el dinero
entregado eso sí ningún país tiene la
obligación de pedir ni aceptar su ayuda
de hecho hay precedentes de países que
se han negado a trabajar con este
organismo pero si acepta su dinero y sus
condiciones luego no vale decir que
donde dije digo digo diego no os parece
pero la cuestión es que en el caso de la
argentina los incumplimientos llegaron
muy pero que muy pronto atentos
[Música]
ah
la historia repetida
amigos cuando arturo frondizi asumió la
presidencia de la argentina en 1958 el
país volvió a pedir ayuda al fmi
en esa ocasión la condición de este
organismo fue que a cambio de recibir el
dinero el país tendría que impulsar un
importante recorte del gasto público y
eliminar controles de precios así como
las restricciones a las importaciones y
cargarse la política de sustitución de
importaciones
pero sabéis que pues una vez que
recibieron el dinero
digamos que el plan de ajuste pues nunca
se cumplió de hecho el siguiente
gobierno el de arturo umberto illia
decidió distanciarse de las
recomendaciones del fondo pero claro las
cosas pues no mejoraron todo lo
contrario
juan carlos onganía juro por dios
nuestro señor y especial su evangelio
desempeñar con lealtad y patriotismo el
cargo del presidente de la nación y tras
el golpe militar del año 1966 liderado
por juan carlos onganía el país volvió a
echarse en manos otra vez del fm y en
esta ocasión las condiciones del
organismo internacional fueron más duras
pero aún así el gobierno argentino pues
digamos que nunca corrigió sus
desequilibrios de tal forma que entre
1966 y 1973 la deuda externa argentina
creció en un 50 por ciento hasta los
4.800 millones el equivalente hoy a casi
30 mil millones de dólares como veis ya
los sucesos no se diferenciaban mucho a
lo que hemos vivido en los últimos años
pero amigos el romance no había hecho
más que comenzar
[Aplausos]
yo anoche una velada artística ofrecida
en el trono del gran palacio del pueblo
de pekín tres años más tarde en 1975 se
produjo el golpe militar de jorge rafael
videla en ese momento la economía está
otra vez hecha pedazos el país venía de
una crisis económica que para que os
hagáis una idea se tradujo en el llamado
rodrigazo una brutal devaluación de la
moneda del cien por cien sobre el dólar
que no sólo causó una enorme inflación
sino también un desabastecimiento de
muchos tipos de productos
y en esas circunstancias os hago una
pregunta que pensáis que hizo el
gobierno militar
exactamente volver a echarse en manos
del fbi de hecho el gobierno de videla
mantuvo unas relaciones muy estrechas
con este organismo y un gran torrente de
dinero del fondo fluyó hacia la
argentina si ya os hemos contado aquí en
visual político que durante esa época en
washington se veía con buenos ojos a
cualquier dictadura que no comulgara con
el bloque soviético con moscú por muy
criminal que ésta fuese seguro que se
influyó en la enorme cantidad de dinero
que el fm y dirigió hacia la argentina
el caso es que el gobierno de videla
sorpresa en cierto modo sí cumplió con
las exigencias del fmi respecto a la
estabilización económica pero lo que no
hizo fue recortar el gasto público con
lo que los desequilibrios fiscales y la
demanda de fondos para financiar al
gobierno pues fue continua
[Música]
por cierto en un próximo vídeo aquí en
visual político hablaremos largo y
tendido de las políticas promulgadas por
el fm y del propio fondo ya veréis por
qué tiene tela y amigos el fm y como os
hemos dicho no es una ong ni mucho menos
sino un prestamista que le presta en
condiciones favorables sí pero es un
prestamista que tiene la intención de
recuperar su dinero durante la dictadura
en apenas siete años la deuda externa de
la argentina se multiplicó por seis
hasta alcanzar la bestial cifra de 42
mil millones de dólares de la época
evidentemente el país estaba quebrado y
para colmo este periodo bajo gobierno
militar terminó con el desastre de las
malvinas de mal en peor están
instalándose en momentos en que vemos al
doctor raúl alfonsín
raúl ricardo alfonsín juro por dios
nuestro señor no ha habido recesión de
hecho ha crecido la economía del país
tras este último coletazo se produjo la
vuelta a la democracia con la llegada al
poder de raúl alfonsín el 10 de
diciembre de 1983 y sabéis que la
democracia yo con muchas expectativas
con la democracia se come se cura y se
educa raúl alfonsín desgraciadamente
esta profecía nunca se cumplió pero no
nos desviemos a su llegada al poder
alfonsín rechazo al fondo incluso
anunció un auditoría de la deuda
contraída por el gobierno militar todo
un gesto de soberanía sabéis qué ocurrió
pues que dos años más tarde de 1985 va a
una colosal montaña de deuda y una
inflación creciente el gobierno de
alfonsín pues volvió a pedir ayuda al
fondo ya sabéis hoy te quiero mañana no
te quiero pasado te vuelvo a querer
etcétera etcétera que tierna historia
el fbi puso condiciones pero las
promesas se quedaron en eso en promesas
así que el mandato de alfonsín acabó de
forma desastrosa con una crisis salvaje
y una hiperinflación de aúpa para que os
hagáis una idea la inflación de 1989 fue
de más del 2000 por cien
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y luego llegó menem y con él un nuevo
apoyo del fmi el plan brady
un plan que obligó a la argentina a
reestructurar su deuda externa
privatizar el sistema de seguridad
social privatizar empresas públicas
eliminar impuestos a las transacciones
financieras y crear una nueva moneda
atada al dólar para evitar la endémica
inflación del país durante la etapa de
menem especialmente durante su primera
legislatura se hicieron muchas cosas y
funcionaron pero una vez más no hizo lo
más difícil ajustar el gasto público de
hecho todo lo contrario bajo el mandato
de este presidente el gasto público
continuó creciendo y con él la deuda
externa del gobierno fijaos
de esta forma el mandato de menem
terminó con otra crisis enorme que acabó
en el famoso default de diciembre del
2001 meses después de que el fmi y
otorgar al gobierno de fernando de la
rúa un mega rescate de 40 mil millones
de dólares conocido como el blindaje
blindaje que duró apenas 10 meses hasta
el definitivo default de 2001
y después de eso llegó una nueva crisis
que hizo disparar la pobreza en
argentina por encima del 50% de la
población
amigos como veis todos los rescates del
fm ya han terminado siempre en un sonoro
fracaso y es normal el fm y puede dar
oxígeno a un país para que éste
equilibre sus cuentas pero si no lo hace
el resultado va a ser siempre el mismo
una y otra y otra vez y en argentina se
han hecho muchas cosas excepto abrir
realmente la economía y recortar el
gasto público y el tamaño del estado que
es gigantesco queréis un ejemplo pues
fijaos en este gráfico que ya os hemos
enseñado en alguna que otra ocasión pero
es que asusta de verdad
[Música]
y ojo no penséis que para el fm y esto
ha sido un plato de buen gusto para nada
argentina ha sido la demostración de la
incapacidad de este organismo ha sido
algo así como una humillación constante
porque los políticos argentinos
aceptaron el dinero pero luego nunca
corregía en los problemas y así pues
claro no se puede es que no se puede
pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando qué
diantres pasó con el kirchnerismo al fin
y al cabo nunca recurrieron al fmi
porque mauricio macri si lo hizo atentos
soportando los apretujones y lo que
aprieta que no pueden hacer pero no nos
van a quebrar compañeros compañeras
trabajado toda mi vida y ha sido una muy
exitosa abogada ahora soy una chica está
presidente también
los kirchner
es verdad los kirchner nunca pidieron
ayuda al fmi pero amigos esta historia
tiene trampas tras el default del 2001
argentina nunca llegó a pagar la mayor
parte de su deuda nominal eso supuso
toda una reestructuración que alivió las
cuentas públicas a esto le tenemos que
sumar que durante la mayor parte de años
del kirchnerismo el precio de la soja y
de los recursos naturales que el país
exporta estuvieron por las nubes eso
supuso una enorme entrada de dólares así
que el gobierno de los kirchner tuvo
margen tuvo aire para seguir expandiendo
el gasto público sin tener que recurrir
al fmi el problema es que eso es pan
para un día y hambre para el resto del
calendario cuando el precio de la soja y
de otras materias primas se vino abajo
los problemas del gobierno volvieron a
estar bajo la mesa y por supuesto
regresaron los controles de precios los
controles cambiarios y las restricciones
de todo tipo eso fue precisamente lo que
llevó a mauricio macri a la casa rosada
pero con macri las cosas tampoco
cambiaron esencialmente el gasto público
continuó por las nubes y el gradualismo
fue tan gradual que la mayor parte de
las reformas nunca llegaron el oxígeno
se terminó y con él la autonomía de la
economía argentina así que en mayo de
2018 el gobierno pidió un nuevo rescate
al fmi en este caso de más de 50 mil
50.000 millones de dólares
y vuelta a empezar el fmi pone
condiciones y los políticos argentinos
no quieren cumplirlas la crisis crece y
entonces los políticos utilizan al fmi
como chivo expiatorio
luego rechazan al organismo
internacional
y entonces llega la etapa del odio y
finalmente de nuevo se echan a sus
brazos
amigos esta es la historia de nunca
acabar de tres años 50 de media
argentina ha pedido un rescate el fm y
cada cuatro años y medio y nunca ha
funcionado no es hora ya de cambiar no
es acaso el momento de que los políticos
argentinos entiendan que lo que necesita
el país es un cambio de verdad no es
acaso también el momento de que el
femení entienda que realmente nunca ha
ayudado a la argentina porque ha
prolongado un escenario que está
llevando al país de mal en peor pero qué
pensáis vosotros abramos debate dejadme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
si este vídeo se ha roto interesante no
olvidéis suscribiros y darle a like una
vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima le pagamos del
disfruto
le damos nuestras soberanías recuperamos
nuestra habilidad y el fondo monetario
internacional claudio y demás a consumir
lo decidido de la economía de la patria
como entró durante tanto tiempo